[Music]
congratulations are in order for a
member of mama June's family a source
tells ET her eldest daughter Lauren
pumpkin Shannon married fiance Joshua
Efford over the weekend adding that
cameras were there and it will be
featured on the new season of June's we
TV show according to reports the couple
tied the knot in Las Vegas and
celebrated with dinner at Buca di Beppo
following their I Do's mama June and
pumpkins younger sister Alana honey boo
boo Thompson will reportedly buy the
newlyweds side we don't really like to
talk about like you know serious stuff
but I got a feeling nothing to change
pumpkin and Josh got engaged in June
2016 and celebrated another major
milestone the following year I got a bun
in the oven chili I'm pregnant the
couple welcomed their daughter Ella
grace in December I'm really excited to
be a new mom and little Ella has already
made her red carpet debut here's the
newborn posing it up with her proud mama
in January at the season 2 premiere of
growing up hip hop Atlanta
[Music]
[Applause]